y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en france 24 para ello me acompaña
daniela blandón daniela buena noche
bienvenida comenzamos el banco de
desarrollo de américa latina tiene un
nuevo presidente de quién se trata
hola raúl que tal mire el colombiano
sergio díaz granados asumirán las
riendas de lo que antes se conocía como
la corporación andina de fomento y que
hoy es el segundo financiadora en
américa latina después del banco
interamericano de desarrollo y llega
tras la dimisión del peruano luis
carranza de cuya gestión trascendieron
denuncias sobre despidos masivos y acoso
laboral entre otras
díaz granados quien había sido ministro
de comercio en el gobierno de juan
manuel santos y hoy representante de
colombia del bid asumirá el cargo el
próximo primero de septiembre por un
período de cinco años se impuso por
mayoría sobre el argentino christian
asinelli la segunda derrota para las
postulaciones del gobierno de alberto
fernández que recordemos a última hora
también retiró la candidatura a la
presidencia del bebé cuando vio que eeuu
iba ganando en la contienda así está ni
en chile 6 pero la pobreza
por 19 eso lo dijo el ministerio de
desarrollo social que hizo una
comparación entre el índice de pobreza
de 2020 o sea pleno año de pandemia y el
que había en 2017 que era el último dato
oficial disponible ahora veamos lo que
encontró la tasa se disparó del 8,6 por
ciento al 10 8% en este periodo sobre
todo el último año debido a la crisis
sanitaria esto equivale raúl a unos 2,1
millones de personas que se encuentran
en esta condición de pobres en cuanto a
la pobreza extrema el dato a 2020 habla
de un 43 por ciento de la población es
decir un poco más de 800 mil personas
casi el doble de 2017 cuando la
proporción era del 23 por ciento en
chile raúl recordamos que el problema
más allá de la pobreza es la desigualdad
apenas al 1 por ciento de los hogares de
mayores ingresos acapara más de una
cuarta parte de la riqueza del país y
cambiamos nuevamente información porque
la empresa del hombre más rico del mundo
cambió de presidente estamos hablando
por supuesto de la multinacional de
comercio electrónico
que hizo relevo hoy por andy jaycee el
cerebro detrás de su lucrativa división
de computación en la nube y quien ahora
será el consejero delegado el lunes fue
el último día del jefe besos al frente
de la compañía aunque seguirá siendo el
presidente ejecutivo el hoy considerado
el hombre más rico del mundo fundó y
llevaba 27 años al frente de una de las
empresas más grandes del planeta que
empezó a vendiendo bienes y ahora ya
llegó hasta hollywood y hasta la luna
también justamente besos anunció meses
atrás que quiere enfocarse en otras
empresas de su conglomerado como blue
over jean quien lo llevará el próximo 20
de julio a un viaje por el espacio y
china- de toda la aplicación por motivos
de seguridad las autoridades de este
país abrieron una investigación de
ciberseguridad contra la empresa de
transporte compartido que es algo así
como el über de ese país también le
exigieron que se retirara de las tiendas
de aplicaciones móviles por abusar de
los datos de los usuarios todo esto
sucedió justo después de una exitosa
salida
wall street' de dir y en eeuu la semana
pasada con la que disparó su valor en
bolsa a más de 80 mil millones de
dólares lo que tiene nerviosos algunos
de sus nuevos inversionistas diddy ya
estaba siendo investigada hace más de un
mes por supuestas prácticas
anticompetitivas por expulsar a sus
rivales más pequeñas
daniela indicadores bueno muy pocos el
día de hoy wall street no operó el lunes
por ser día festivo y tampoco lo
hicieron varios mercados de américa
latina la bolsa de buenos aires ganó un
23 % mientras que la bolsa mexicana
avanzó apenas un 0.66 la bolsa de sao
paulo en cambio retrocedió levemente en
medio de fricciones políticas y nosotros
indicadores el precio del petróleo subió
más del 1 por ciento en la jornada del
lunes hasta 76 dólares en la referencia
w
para finalizar que nos trae como cifra
del día cabo los diecinueve mil 674
millones de dólares a los que subió las
exportaciones peruanas en lo que va
corrido de este año hasta mayo esto
representa un crecimiento del 43 por
ciento lo que quiere decir que se están
recuperando que buena noticia es
entonces esa cifra del día dan y
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información económica a ustedes
también gracias continué con nosotros
aquí en france 24
[Música]